you are walking talking to me hi welcome
to another ColdFusion video
Ubbe it's a company that's known for its
disruption of the taxi industry their
ride-sharing service may getting from
place to place cheaper and easier now
the company is taken to the skies in
this video we'll take a look at what's
happening it just might surprise you
since the Ford 5i an aircraft that was
meant to be the Model T of the skies
it's widely been a dream to have
mass-produced personal aircraft fast
forward to the late 2010 and it seems
like electrical personal aircraft are
picking up steam electrical vertical
takeoff and landing aircraft or veto
aircraft for short are the perfect
design for personal air taxis evey tolls
are quiet have no direct emissions and
are relatively cheap all of which are
properties that helicopters don't share
on previous episodes on this channel
we've already seen the e hung one eighth
floor a Chinese semi-autonomous personal
aircraft which is already starting
flights in Dubai we've also seen a scale
model test flight by the German company
William it seems that uber doesn't want
to miss out on this new emerging
industry in October of last year the
company released a 98 page white paper
in the paper they detailed the vision of
being able to complete a distance of a
two-hour drive in 15 minutes by air
according to studies in cities such as
Los Angeles and Sydney residents spend
seven whole working weeks each year
commuting in Mumbai in India the average
working commute is 90 minutes
Uber's solution is what they're calling
on-demand aviation they want to push for
infrastructure that allows for an urban
VTOL network claiming that this
infrastructure will be significantly
cheaper than building new roads very
recently technology advances have made
it practical to build a new class of
VTOL aircraft the white paper goes on to
say that in order to make this a
successful market they must first
overcome some barriers these include but
aren't limited to the certification
process that is getting a license to fly
it battery technology a revamping of the
urban air traffic control system vehicle
efficiency performance and reliability
and safety in April of this year
uber had their first conference it was
an array of experts working on the
cutting edge of battery technology
aircraft manufacturing charging
technology and also featured regulatory
bodies and think tanks they came
together to cross-pollinate ideas they
pretty much addressed all of the
problems and the white paper
I watched the stream event online and I
was actually surprised at a couple of
things that I saw it actually turns out
that this time the battery technology as
of the CR now exists to make this a
reality we'll get to that bit later but
before we get into the juicy details
here's a bit from Bloomberg with an
interview at France watch apart
uber said it would like to see flying
vehicles being demoed in 2020 is this a
reality how quickly we actually start to
see over using these sorts of flying
vehicles as taxis so yeah I think it's
going to be a reality it's going to
happen much quicker than what we thought
even a year ago because there's a couple
of elements that are already now we look
at the battery and battery they have the
right density the right energy storage
so battery okay is the supercharger
they're ready to so for a small and
short all you're going to be able to
real refuel or recharge your vehicle in
less than five minutes but I really
think is that we're going to see
these first flying cars like this new
mode of transportation drink that their
first test flight by by next year that's
what's wrong okay so let's break all of
this down
uber is calling this new infrastructure
that you were elevate network the point
of the conference was to create new
innovative aircraft that can
revolutionize air transport and package
delivery the company wants a flight
range of about 25 to 60 miles or 40 to
100 kilometres and wants to carry about
two to five passengers they aim to start
flights in Texas and Dubai in the year
2020 some of the engineering teams
getting behind the project come from
companies such as Bell Helicopter Airbus
which is also working on an air traffic
control system called sky waves and also
papers through the Slovenian Electric
Light plane manufacturer that was
featured on this channel a couple of
weeks ago also there was the young
German team William and also a company
called Aurora as it turns out we decided
to use Aurora as its primary partner
Aurora is a media plan was to build an
autonomous aircraft with a safety backup
pilot and room for two passengers or 220
kilograms of luggage the top speed will
be 200 kilometers now and the travel
distance will be 40 kilometers the
design looks rather clunky because they
wanted the simplest design possible no
two loaders direct-drive motors only and
the whole thing has to be built on
existing tech they've already actually
achieved a quarter scale model test
flight and although it looks small it's
about 2 by 2 meters and size this
aircraft is loosely based on the XV 24
ax plane an aircraft that's being
developed for the US Department of
Defense the company was also partnered
with NASA and DARPA ok so let's talk
about batteries absolutely none of this
would make any sense if the battery tech
wasn't there
well what may be surprising is that
there's actually been a lot of progress
made in the past year due to the growing
acceptance that electric cars are under
horizon battery suppliers and others
that are in the battery industry are
forced to push the limits of their
technology in the hope that they can be
a player in this
market David Baxter co-founder and vice
president and the man in charge of
hardware engineering at the company
called charge port gave a presentation
on the current technology that they have
they have a charging station that can
charge batteries from zero to twenty
five percent in five minutes and twenty
five to ninety percent in fifteen
minutes
the secret that enables them to do all
of this is the liquid cooling in their
charging cable charge point states that
they already have the existing
technology in their product called the
Express charge which was released in
early 2017 originally designed for
electric cars the charger can output
four hundred kilowatts and the modules
that make up the station have ninety-six
percent efficiency and a capable of
pushing out a whopping 1250 amps at a
thousand volts we're here with a charge
point Pasquale romano talked about the
new liquid cooled TPS combo charging yes
so the goal for this is to enable a
consumer to be able to dispense about as
much energy you can take to run a car
show
without knowing it so what we did here
is we use gasoline hose as the benchmark
because everyone who touches that liquid
close bright airy technology that gets a
four hundred kilowatt capable connector
to be small light flexible it is very
manipulative to your car and that is all
100 amps okay and 1000 will go from an
optical the company states that their
cooling technology can actually call the
aircraft batteries itself reducing
energy use and in addition to this the
system is also highly scalable next
ersity arc chief technology officer of G
batteries states that since its
introduction in 1991 lithium-ion
batteries have actually been improving
every year but to make a VTOL feasible a
power-to-weight ratio of 300 watt hours
per kilogram and a cost of $400 per
kilowatt hour is needed but in most
production the most you can get is about
a hundred and fifty watt hours per
kilogram and that's happening by Tesla
flux in paracin the Tesla Model S was
about a hundred and thirty watt hours
per kilogram and in this and leaf about
80 watt hours per kilogram in the second
goal of $400 per kilowatt hour has
already been achieved the real problem
is that the charging rate and the life
cycles aren't up to scratch for these
high energy density batteries Nick
states that the reason for this is that
the protocol for charging batteries has
remained unchanged for a hundred years
it's completely unoptimized Nick likens
the moving lithium ions to a packed
freeway less densely populated and
uncontrolled yet people want to move
fast the pile ups and crashes that
inevitably happen are pretty much the
same as when lithium ions create
irreversible chemical reactions in a
words a loss of battery cycle life and
new technology offered by G batteries
called active battery management systems
use a special algorithm to tackle this
problem on the 3000 milliamp hour
battery not unlike something that you'll
find in a regular smartphone they were
getting get this as zero to 50 percent
charge in five minutes
while more than doubling the long-term
battery life in more tests
even outside the lab they saw a 600
percent improvement in the charging rate
and the three to ten times improvement
in long-term battery life these tests
were done on real-world batteries in
products or batteries that you can pick
up at the store so it looks like this
algorithm really seems to work and
there's hard data to back it up I'll
leave a link in the description to the
full talk so you can look and see for
yourself so how does it work well
without going into too much detail the
algorithm stops the loss of cyclin
lithium in the anode of the battery
there's a couple of other talks and
battery technology but another one that
I found interesting was solid energy a
company formed three years ago they're
claiming the lightest rechargeable
batteries ever made with a density at
half the size compared to comparable
batteries so Electric Aviation simply
will not be impossible with the current
battery technology if uber elevat is
going to succeed we need an entirely new
battery we need a paradigm shift in in
terms of how we approach batteries and
today I won't talk about how we solve
these challenges and also how solid
energy you can enable the future of
electric aviation the innovation is
something that they're calling lithium
metal it involves a liquid solvent in a
salt electrolyte and it seems like their
new battery technology is already
working pretty well in industry
situations and the most exciting part of
my job is is to see the exciting
feedback from customers that have tested
Hermes this is this is data from an
aerospace company they've been working
on this project for about 10 years and
so far they've been
just making baby steps because of better
limitations there try looking sulfur
they try Sultan lithium-ion but it's not
ideal then they try our Hermes and and
right away they start breaking all kinds
of world records and right now their
product is commercially available and
they tell us that we are time travelers
from the future to help them and I
believe the same thing will happen for
it for the evo applications I think it's
important that as a battery company that
we stop playing with fancy science and
focus on real-world results the state of
empty promises and fake news in the
battery industry must stop so in
conclusion with the major hurdle of
batteries coming close to being overcome
it seems like ubers vision of a personal
air taxi network could actually become a
reality whether this all happens or not
still remains to be seen but I'm
cautiously optimistic about all of us if
nothing else the push to stronger
battery technology could trickle down to
consumer devices as benefiting us all on
a side note the personal aircraft
industry actually has a close personal
tied to me a company that I'm working at
electro Aero is producing electric
ducted fans for sustainable aviation the
key goal for our company is propulsion
systems that are efficient who all
having a compact footprint so seeing all
of these advances being pushed under the
umbrella of Eva is actually really
interesting to me if you want to check
out what my company is doing I'll leave
a link below in the description we've
already got contracts with large
aerospace companies and have been making
developments in partnership with NASA so
some very interesting times indeed
anyway thanks for watching this video
this has been - go go you're been
watching cold fusion if you did like the
video give it a thumbs up if you need to
the channel feel free to subscribe and
I'll see you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion be thinking
[Music]